make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again
with juggernaut yes we're back again
with the juggernaut solo series written
by fabian neciza probably one of the
coolest writers that marvel has
and we're picking up with a trial of of
juggernaut right this is where the
juggernaut was basically summoned to
court
for all the damage he's caused or at
least a huge chunk of damage that he's
caused and what they're using here is
evidence for a fight between himself and
spider-man
and they're kind of pointing out the
idea that like the fight between the two
of them had caused millions of dollars
worth of damage right and that kane
marco was not being mind controlled
right his actual his actions were his
own
his choices were his own and that
carmine angelo right this kind of new
york city born and bred guy
lost his scrappy construction company
now the whole thing is kind of being
watched by diesel
and technically i guess she can record
it because she's considered herself to
be part of the press which what really
makes a person part of the press right i
don't know if you really have to have
like press credentials
per se i think it's just like i've got a
phone and i want to document this so i
am part of the press now whether or not
you're recognized that way by the rest
of the press
is a whole different discussion but one
of the things that kind of comes out of
this and this is what's cool
is that you have the the defense
attorney essentially for kane marco
coming out and saying yeah
but kane marco was not the one who
destroyed this guy's you know this this
guy's cement right this guy's wholesome
company that was spider-man who did that
that was collateral damage of the
conflict and spider-man was the one who
caused it now
this is one of the interesting things
you don't really see here because when
it comes to the superheroes and the
super villains fighting each other
on the whole all the collateral damage
this gets done right so buildings being
torn up
or or being smashed and destroyed things
like that that's all handled by damage
control incorporated right it's a
company with a government contract to
clean up after the superheroes and they
don't really differentiate between who
did what it's just a matter of
this was destroyed and then that's it
they usually use something like
eyewitness evidence or or video evidence
or something along those lines to kind
of figure out who caused what damage but
in this instance kane marco was also
stuck inside that concrete for months
right like for months on in but
spider-man is really the one that kind
of brought this down now it's not
because spider-man was being being
terrible is because that's just the
nature of what happens when superheroes
fight super villains and so in the midst
of this whole trial
everything basically goes south and what
you end up getting is the arrival
of essentially a sandman character but
not the sandman that you're used to but
before we get into that we actually end
up jumping back
to a few months ago and kind of get this
explanation of how it was
that kane marco got his powers and this
is somewhat of an interesting concept
that marvel's rolling in here
in his journey to find a new juggernaut
suit he's basically brought to north
korea and as he gets there he ends up
finding what is and essentially
the forge of sidorak right now the forge
of rack is this
this concept designed to basically build
things that are in the likeness of
sidorak or to honor sidorak that's kind
of the way this all works we talked
about the octescence the fact that
sidorak is one of eight demon entities
uh that was the kind of was part of a
giant competition to essentially take
control of the world and whoever it was
you know whoever's forces end up
destroying the other forces would come
out on top i guess a little more
explanations needed there so what you
have is the octescence and this is
basically eight demon entities um each
of which we're arguing over who's the
most powerful
and the way this worked is that each one
of them put an artifact on earth and
when the first artifact was picked up it
would begin the octescence and that's
what happened with kane marco
he picked up the crimson gem of sidorak
he became the juggernaut but he also
started the octescence now that whole
thing came to a head
in the eighth day storyline but the idea
is that once the first artifact was
picked up it would drive seven other
people to want to grab the other
artifacts and they in turn would would
split humanity into eighths and then
they would all go to war with each other
and whichever army came out on top that
being out there
that represents that army would prove to
be the most powerful one so if
juggernaut basically you know wiped out
all the other avatars of the other demon
entities and then wiped out all the
other
7 8 of humanity then it would prove that
that sidorak was the most powerful now
the eighth day event was stopped
especially because of thor he had a huge
hand in that but this is the reason why
these kind of forges are created
is because they're designed to honor
these various entities and there's some
out there like for like watum different
people out there you know different
beings out there like that there's other
forges out there and other artifacts out
there like that we just don't really see
them anymore but when kane marco gets in
here
he's basically looking for a new suit
and he tells the guy this and the guy's
like well a lot of people have come here
looking for
you know something of cedar rack looking
to serve as the host of cedar rack what
makes you special
and that's when kane marco reveals he's
actually the juggernaut and the guy
points up above and you basically see
that a new suit's been created out of
the crimson bands of sidorak the crimson
bands of sidorak are historically
something used by steven strange and
that's one of the things to understand
about doctor strange himself is he
doesn't really have
any powers unto himself instead his
powers are lent to him
by other people while they're lent to
him by other beings sorry sidorak for
example
lends doctor strange the crimson bands
now it seems as though these crimson
bands are no longer being linked to
steven strange because now they're being
forged into a new suit of armor and
that's what this guy does right now
though the other problem with this
is that he spent all this time building
this armor under the belief that sidorak
would see what he'd done
and then see him as a new host right he
would say like you know i bless you with
becoming my new avatar because of the
work you've put in to make this soup but
as we know center axe is kind of a jerk
and that never happened it seemed like
sidorak was just waiting for kane marco
to return
and so the two of them essentially get
into a kind of scuffle right but
ultimately uh kane marco ends up coming
out on top
and uh in in this whole great big huge
fight the the chains that are holding
the suit up are basically destroyed and
when that happens the suit falls onto
kane marco
and bonds itself to him and he emerges
as the new juggernaut and that's how he
got his new suit now
what its full capabilities are we don't
entirely know usually whenever marvel
changes
up the suit of a character especially if
somebody like juggernaut because his
powers
come from the crimson gym it stands to
reason that there will be upgrades right
there'll be changes we saw that with
donnie kate's
venom for example when venom encountered
null he was awakened to a whole new host
of abilities he didn't realize he had
before so that's usually what ends up
happening here is that things end up
shifting up
jumping back to the current moment right
now you end up having d cell kind of
holding off this sandman s character
as best as you possibly can the funny
thing about this is that the voice
that's emanating from sandman which
basically says like give me the girl
and uh and no one will get hurt this all
does this voice really seems to be
female and as we know historically
sandman is a guy not only that this
voice is german right and so it doesn't
look like it's the actual sandman it
looks like somebody who has the powers
of sandman right who took his powers or
something along those lines but then of
course diesel kind of chimes in and says
her name is quicksand um and so what you
end up getting is of course juggernaut
jumping in but the funny thing about him
is that much like the fights with
spider-man
you can't really fight sandman in the
traditional sense you can't punch you
know anybody who's able to use sand
in that way because it's sand what all
they do is create an opening where you
fly right through them
or something like that instead you have
to do what spider-man historically did
which is use water
right that's what you normally have to
do but kane marco hasn't quite figured
that out yet and in fact it's not even
really kane marco who figures that out
instead when you have this great big
huge conflict and you have uh d
cell kind of watching all this unfold
there's a couple things that happen here
the first is that d-cell is referred to
as a mute hence the reason why i said in
the last video
that's probably what she's gonna end up
being the second thing that's referred
to here
is that they basically realize that she
has a kind of energy source in her head
and in order to basically stop her
you've got to remove her head
essentially now again this is where
things get a little murky here because
we don't know if she's an actual being
if she's just some kind of psychic
entity that took on a you know energetic
form and just
coalesced into a form of sand and that's
where we are right now we don't really
know how all that works but what we do
know
is that they end up basically severing
this kind of energy source in the head
from the rest of the body and when k
mark was able to pull that off when he
does that kind of using this
great big huge piece of metal like a
sword when he cuts it off and basically
beheads the girl
uh which is kind of screwed up that's
when this energy source is extracted
and when it's extracted there's this
kind of realization they sort of go
through and start analyzing it and they
realize this has a somewhat unique
energy signature and that this energy
signature that it has
comes from only one particular location
and when the question is where's this
location coming from
that it basically comes from absolution
solutions right now
anybody who knows anything about
absolution solutions knows who it is
that runs this whole program that their
director of research
is artem zola right like the old school
villain now before you guys are kind of
like yeah
you know any kind of sucks arnhem zola
in more recent years especially during
rick remender's run of captain america
was actually amazing like he
literally had his own pocket dimension
that he had sort of cultivated and
created
and captain america was actually stuck
in there for a ton arnomzola the funny
thing about him is he's a highly capable
scientist he's just one of these guys
that largely gets ignored by marvel
which you wouldn't think would be the
case especially in the aftermath of
captain america the winter soldier um i
guess you really haven't seen a lot from
arnhem zola since then but he's quite
quite literally one of the most
dangerous minds in all of
of marvel comics right so i'm kind of
curious to see where they go with this
right i'm kind of curious to see what's
happening but the big takeaway is that
arnhem zola is experimenting
on superhuman prisoners so who knows
what kind of forces we're going to see
the juggernaut face off against which is
really what i'm the most excited for but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign